i'm here to perform the art of freestyle
rap for you
of course invented in england
it's wrapped it's made up on the spot
it's improvised not really not dependent
on rehearsals and it's based on your
suggestion so everyone here think of a
word think the topic thing for phrase
you'd like to hear a wrap about there
are some rules don't save one second
don't say food all animals aren't too
obvious okay be creative best suggestion
ever was a german man who said a day in
the life of an aztec high priest
so you said you said kanye west what is
it about kanye west that entices you so
a man undergoing severe mental health
struggles
[Music]
everything but be more specific like
kanye west surfing or kanye west
eating you know lollipop or whatever
no you can you can make it up it doesn't
have to be real kenya west has never
eaten all the folks
yeah
oh you didn't listen to what the
instructor before just showing kanye
west did you get confused now i was like
i'm gonna rap and you were like this is
kanye west i've never
it's hard to decipher behind those big
shades with the lines in
well what we can do we can come to this
side of the room so let's let's get
stretched from this side of the room
what do you guys want to wrap up
obama pleasuring himself yeah cool why
not
i waited someone the thing is that is a
great suggestion and then chicago is
just a location
wait what do you say
you could do that well because they're
both black is that why you said that
they're called chicago how are they both
from chicago
[Music]
issue with that we just want to turn up
and make places better
and steal all your things but also
are you from a place that we colonized
no okay
you can do better do better than that no
i got one for you yeah do it
you're an alien and you're watching all
this [ __ ]
an alien watching all this [ __ ]
just yeah man that's cool okay obama
pleasuring himself an alien watching all
this crazy [ __ ]
i i bet you spend a lot of time on
reddit that's what that makes me feel
like um that's not a dis that's a good
place to be people over here what would
you like a rapport
look you don't have to base it on what
they say
although the easiest album is my
favorite candy album and that is the one
where he first produces the concept of
eating ass and at the time everyone's
like kenya you crazy which is not the
word you should use because he generally
does suffer from mental health issues
and now everyone's eating ass he's a
trendsetter right
everyone uses autotune and sparse
arrangements this man's a genius and you
need to
need to respect sir okay so what we'll
just say we've got kanto kanye eating
ass aliens watching all this [ __ ] obama
pleasuring himself um let's let's get uh
let's get another one british women
british women yeah are you british
no you haven't [ __ ] a british girl no
way no way
what's wrong with my girls man
their teeth are [ __ ] up yeah they snag
on your [ __ ] whatever
they're orange well they are if they're
in essex or newcastle that is true yeah
okay yep that's really that's that's two
strikes against british women okay so
to remind you then we've got kanye ian
ass
god this is why i don't do late shows
because you're all vulgar
obama pleasuring himself
we've got um british women and how
they're you don't want to [ __ ] them
aliens watching all this [ __ ]
and um
colonization i guess we'll throw in
there right let me this is all tangled
up for some reason i bet this was
kevin's doing
trying to sabotage me right okay cool
this is a free stuff that's a wrap made
up on the spot based on all that [ __ ]
it's uh it's gonna be fun and not as
[ __ ] as you expected to be
unless
[Music]
rocking up the first president with the
darker skin than anyone before and to
their chagrin he'd be there yeah he does
it real properly get a hand shandy in
the oval office
on the resolute desk we know that obama
did it best because he's a self-starter
dick bigger than jimmy carter or jfk i'm
a charmer wanking gary gets an issue
does he use a presidential sock or a
tissue i don't know it goes so well the
cops swell when he nuts and he's like
michelle come on here so much come and
she's swimming the only thing he won't
[ __ ] white women from my country
in the uk
that's why you say you like nakris
they're ever so deranged they got bad
molars and they're so orange i wanna
make sure they're not the color of flame
maybe in the future we'll colonize again
we're gonna run round yeah we're in for
sure we're gonna go take china and india
once more then i'll tell you what the
queen do coming over here and she invade
you admittedly she's properly dead by
then but prince charles will come in
inviting lights off joe biden i'm the
prince coming in with the clock now what
do you think and joe's down there on the
floor saying oh i'm sorry charles yes
you know that i adore the empire that
you had fancy that thing that we tried
to join you with iraq and afghanistan we
went we were like a team kanye west our
man is such a dream with production and
all the raps i'm about in late
graduation college drop out but then he
did stuff more recently like ye i was
like not pleased to see that [ __ ]
but you don't mind top class when i
listen to yeezus oh my you blew my mind
i was like this is a blast i wanna crank
up the [ __ ] while he's eating ass he was
getting right there some people say it's
wrong but he's probing the rectum with
his tongue and when he's down there with
her ass cheeks played probably he was
wearing those shades i was like oh lick
it while the shit's brown i call that a
real love lock down there we go [ __ ] on
his mouth he can't talk but still he
made through the wire and jesus walked
[Applause]